hi i'm dana moshkovitz and i'm going to
uh speak about a reduction from
non-unique games to booty and unique
games this is joint work with ronan
aldan
okay so here's a big picture of uh of
this work
uh if we want to prove the only game's
conjecture uh we need to show a
reduction from a problem that's known to
be np hard
to unique games okay
in 2016
as bash code and i had a paper
where we suggested to focus on the
boolean version of the unique games
and then we showed the candidate
reduction from a known empty heart
problem a problem that we showed was npr
a few years before that
um
two boolean unique games okay and i
should say
in our mind uh boolean unique games how
the support in uni games already
captures the heart of the uni games
conjecture
however to get the full unique games
conjecture from the boolean version you
need to
to do what's called strong pair
repetition of unique games
which is
an extremely fascinating uh
problem
lots and lots of tweets it's a very
interesting story but but it's um
not this work so we won't talk about it
more here
okay so so all we want is to prove
hardness of boolean unit gains there is
a reduction uh let me say that the
reductions reduction from 2016 had some
problems
for one it wasn't the polynomial time
reduction it was an exponential time
reduction
uh
and the idea was that it would rule out
um
uh right it's like not not two to the n
but but slightly better um
uh so it would rule out uh polynomial
time algorithms for boolean unique games
assuming that south requires exponential
time
so so this is one disadvantage uh
another disadvantage well there were
some concerns about whether it was
actually sound or not it was just a
candidate we didn't prove a correctness
um
and and even though this reduction has
the ideas that we believe should should
prove hardness of brilliant unique games
we did make one technical choice
specifically for anyone who knows
using periodic half spaces instead of
half spaces
um
and this technical choice seemed to be
fishy
there were concerns about whether
whether the reduction can be some
because of that
um
so so this is it this was 2016.
um
actually already back then ronan and dan
and i
decided that we'll try to analyze uh
this reduction or a similar reduction
um and and the result is is uh this work
so so we do two things uh for one we we
take this reduction
um the 2016 reduction and we figure out
how to do it right
as in
uh we we uh
outline a reduction that is actually
polynomial time
so it's as np hardness reduction
and we get rid of this periodic half
space
uh we just use half spaces when coding
uh so this seems like really clean and
and and
reasonable and and
very likely to be sound reduction okay
so so this is one contribution we
actually get
this uh the odd reduction right
um
the other contribution is we actually
managed to prove soundness
actually managed to analyze the
reduction but not quite the original
reduction instead
what we do
is we come up with a new game with a new
with a new um
with a new problem
uh that we wish
was np hard it's it's similar to
problems that are known to be empty hard
um
and but but we don't know how to prove
and be hardness we do know how to rule
out we know that semi-definite
programming based algorithms won't
won't solve it um
but
but we don't quite know how to prove np
hardness for it um but for this related
problem we're able to take a reduction
that is
uh analogous to this
2016 the candidate hard unit game
and and we are able to analyze this
reduction um
and and
from from this wishful and b hardness to
uh to the to boolean unique games okay
so so this is what this work is about
um here's what i want to do in the talk
so one thing
is uh the first thing i'll do is i'll
take um
a
boolean unit games and i'll explain to
you boolean unique games right so i'm
going to define this boolean union games
conjecture um
right and
right so this is the first thing
second i'm going to talk about np
hardness results um so what's known so
i'll talk about some of the of the
strongest pcp theorems that there are um
so i'll talk about specifically the pcp
theorem that is in this you know 2016
reduction
in and this will set the stage to talk
about this wishful uh pcp theorem
um that that we need um
and finally i'm going to talk about the
main
technical component
in the in the analysis of the reduction
so there is actually a mathematical
theorem a new concentration theorem that
is
in my opinion of completely independent
interest
um
and and i'll i'll talk to you about that
okay
so so this is the this is the plan for
the talk of course right the the the the
overall the point of the talk is that
uh now we did that right the next stage
is to actually
bring back the reduction to
be a reduction from a known and hard
problem to to uh boolean indigenes and
eventually
improve the
boolean uniques conjecture
okay
so uh so let's let's do it
the first thing is let's talk about the
boolean unique games conjecture so
really this is a this is a problem about
max cut max cut is like the basic a
unique game
yes you're given a graph
and and the task is to
partition the the vertices into two such
that there are as many edges as possible
um
in that cross the cut
um and and the case that we'll uh
concentrate on is the case where
um there is a card that says that that
that costs that almost all the edges
cross so one minus delta fraction of the
edge is cosy and you need to find a cut
that that also causes that most of the
most of the edges
okay so so this is this picture here
almost all the edges close except for
this this red edge okay so to tell you
what's known about this problem i have
this scale on the right so
this this
axis is for the fraction of edges that
you cross okay so we know that there is
a card that crosses one minus delta
fraction of the edges and the question
is
how many edges can
can we cross
okay
let me just mention right why this is a
unique game um you can think of every
edge has a constraint right um so every
every vertex is supposed to get a beat
or you're on one side of the cut or the
other side of the cards they're all one
um and and every edge wants its two end
points to have uh different signs or
different different beats um right so
if you know the beat on one side you
know what's a bit on the other side and
vice versa
so so this is this is uniqueness the end
point that the assignment one endpoint
dictates the assignment the other
endpoint okay so this is the
basic unit game
okay so let's go back to our axis what
what's known about this max cut problem
um okay so so for once uh so so right as
usual um
right if there is no gap so the first
question is suppose that there is a cut
that one minus the fraction of the edges
cross and you're trying to find
a cut well one minus delta fraction of
the edges cross
this is known to be an empty health
problem
right so so this is there is no gap
right this is an exact and we have
problem and the question is what happens
as you you
kind of grow a gap
er as the ground the gap grows more and
more as you ask the algorithm to do less
and less right the number of edges for
the the truth cause is is smaller and
smaller alright the problem becomes
easier so the question is when when does
it cost to
to being easy
so here's what's known um
by work of fastadjuang manokwan
we know that
um
even though there is a card that is one
minus delta function has one minus zero
function of the edges you'll be able to
find the car
the problem of finding a cut where um
the 1 minus 11 over 8 delta fraction uh
of the edges
a
cos right this is going to be an empty
help problem all right so so we have
some np hardness result here
um there is a good reasons to think that
this could
um
that that this could be improved to one
minus two delta but um
at this very moment this is still
unknown
um
okay what about algorithms so there is
the commands williamson algorithm the
government's williams williamson
semi-definite programming based
algorithm would manage to find a cut
that causes one minus square delta
function of the edges with a very
specific constant here in front of the
square data
um
and now notice that there is this big
part here in the middle well well we
don't have results right there's no
algorithm there is no hardness what what
there is
is a beautiful work of
of a cot killer mozelle
that shows that if the only game's
conjecture is true
then
um
er the the gomes williamson algorithm is
the best you can do okay so beating it
is np heart okay so we think that the
the hardness should extend all the way
to the one minus four delta
e regime
eh
but but it's not known and and this is
where this boolean unigames conjecture
um
comes in so so here's a conjecture for
any
large constant right a million one is
sufficiently small delta um it's np hard
to distinguish between one minus delta
versus one minus c delta right one minus
delta versus one minus million delta
so this is np hard right so this is the
regime that is somewhere in the middle
right we're not even asking for you know
the the result that we think is true is
just beating gomez williamson is np how
we're saying okay let's just show and be
harness of one minus delta versus one
minus large constant delta
um right so so this is an easier regime
to work with
and
if we pull off this this strong prior
repetition for unique games this is the
only thing you you need right so if you
prove that you'll get the full uni games
conjecture
right so this is why we we concentrate
on on this question
okay
next
um so so the next thing i want to talk
to you about uh what are what what are
the empty hardness results that are
known
um so what can we reduce form
and i want to start with projection
games this is the foundation of optimal
inapproximability results
um
basically all the the optimal inner
possibility results that we have start
with projection games unique games our
fellow strengthening of projection games
right so this is a very important object
in in approximability
now um
pcps can be described in the in the
language of
games so so this is what i'll do
okay so here's here's a took over game
or rather a whole pattern for uh to
cover games a family of two google games
there are two provers or two players
player and player b
each gets a question
and each should return a vector right so
think of it as as vector of beats so
there is a vector u you get from a that
will be a v that you get from b
okay so for concreteness you can think
of maybe we have some satin instance and
formula that we want to figure out
whether it's satisfiable or not and we
asked player hey oh can you give me the
assignments for these
variables and you ask there b or can you
give me the assignment for those
variables and maybe the assignment to a
the the the variables that a is given
spend some tests
the the the
assignments of player b
spend some tests
and um
usually what you do is you have an
overlap
between the the the set of variables
that you give to a that's the variables
that you give to b so you'll be able to
compare them you can make sure that
they're consistent and if they're
consistent it makes sense that that um
um
that there is actually a global
assignment
that that satisfies the formula okay so
projection game
is a game in which the very fire does
exactly two things first there is some
predicate it checks on on each vector
right so so this predicate would be like
okay is this a a reasonable
assignment this is a satisfying
assignment to those variables maybe
those variables spend some constraints
of the satellite will check those
constraints
okay so so in each
vector you're allowed to check whatever
you want
but then the only thing you check
between vectors
is uh you check that out the same on
some uh um
subset of the of the bits
okay so there is some subset of the
coordinates in u some subsets of the
coordinates in v and those should be
exactly the same right so think of it as
the
the
assignments to the
um to the overlap in the in the set of
of uh variables we ask about
okay so this is this is what's known as
a symmetric projection game um right
it's projection because you take the
vector and all you care about when you
come to compel you you project
into this overlap and you check whether
the overlaps are the same
okay
so so these are these are projection
games and for projection games we know
extremely extremely strong how test
results
um so so let me define the the value of
the game as the maximum of all possible
strategies of the players of the
probability that the value file accepts
the pcp theorem says for any epsilon
larger than zero it's np how to
distinguish whether the value is one or
epsilon okay so even if you know that
there is strategy for the player for the
players that makes a very fun always
accept
it's going to be np hard to find um
a strategy that makes the
the verified acceptance probability even
just epsilon okay this is true for any
epsilon so the gap is as loud as it can
be it's gap that is that approaches one
okay and it even epsilon can even you
know go down to zero with with and the
input size so so we know this
ridiculously strong theorem
let me also mention
if the predicate that the valid file
checks on each on each vector separately
is linear
uh then we also have this gap one
uh but we need to change the the
completeness so it's one minus delta
versus epsilon because for linear games
uh to check whether it's fully if there
is
a strategy that is that is um
fully satisfiable then then you can just
find it by solving linear equations
okay but but there is hardness for
distinguish between uh the value is is
very close to one and the value is close
to zero
okay so we basically have everything we
want for for projection games
but this theorem can be even
strengthened even more uh so
so the big strengthening came in 2018
this is the two to two theorem
alternatively you could call the two to
two theom the giant overlap
theorem because this is what it says it
says that you can still get this super
strong one minus delta versus epsilon a
harness result even when the overlap
between the two players is gigantic
so even when the overlap reveals almost
all the information about the vectors so
given the overlap there are only two
options for you
also given the overlap the only two
options for b this v this is why it's
called two to two
and even then there is still this gap
one
uh
between the two players
okay
okay so this is this uh
amazing result
um
this is what's known about projection
games okay
now towards the the
endeavor of proving the union games
conjecture improving thousands of
bullion unique games um
subhash and i
suggested to consider projection games
over the reals
and so
the the the big change is that now the
two vectors that that
the players return
are no longer
vectors of beats they are real vectors
okay
and the thing is that we were able to
prove an np hottest result that's
very strong even in this case so here's
what we proved this is from uh
was published in 2011
in
its and be hard
given that there is a strategy well
one thing the victories are always right
so they have some norm and and the norm
is spread over uh all the coordinates um
nicely so rightful sort of regula
so there is this sort of regular uh
strategy for the players that the
verifier accepts with probability one
minus delta
even then if you are trying to find if
you're an efficient algorithm that tries
to find um
a
strategy
er that that does well
right you all in uh bait shape
because it's np how'd to find the
strategy
uh well the the difference
between uh coordinating the overlap
is
uh even just slow delta right so so here
the difference this is the big
difference from the discrete case in the
discrete case right it's all beats so
either
you have exact equality or you have
inequality that's it
this is a much much um
finer
a question here we let the algorithm
get
within
some small
quantity
um
right so so the two coordinates
right in the overlap right it doesn't
have to be exactly the same it can
differ a little
in
and right so this makes the life of the
algorithm much easier and so so proving
an np-harness result
um
it becomes becomes harder um
but but we proved an empty harness
result so so the the
best algorithm so so the best algorithm
that we know
is this semi-definite programming based
algorithm uh right naturally you can
write a semi-definite program for this
for this problem and you're able
uh to to get within square delta right
this algorithm would be able to get
within square root delta in in
the respective coordinates y squared
delta because what you're going to do is
you're going to minimize the expectation
of the difference squared
and you know because there is a strategy
that does so well you know that this
expectation of the different squared is
at most delta right if the norm is say
one something
um
oh right so
so you
you could get this this delta
uh
for the square which means that you can
get square delta for for the difference
and what we showed is that this is best
possible okay so if you're trying
uh to do
to do better than that this is already
going to be np heart
okay so there is always going to be at
least
um a difference of square delta
in the overlap
okay so so this is what what we proved
uh back in the day and and the
right with the the idea of using it as a
starting point
uh for for this hardness reduction
and indeed the the harness reduction
from 2016 starts with this sort of um
wait maybe it's written a bit
differently right but basically this
sort of uh of hardness result
okay and and and let me say i think that
this sort of hardness results should be
the the starting point for uh even an
eventual uh reduction to boolean union
games
okay but we're not able to analyze uh uh
right now a a reduction from from this
problem to boolean unique games instead
we consider a different problem
that is that is similar that you'll see
that it has some similarity to this
problem some similarity to the two to
two
type game
okay but but it's different so so let me
let me define this new opponent that we
consider we call it the subspaces near
until section key
so here is how it goes uh again it's a
twofold game you have two players player
a player b
each player gets a linear subspace in
our k after the k thing of case is large
constant right this is always the case
in those
in those problems like the vector is a
constant dimension of a very large
constant
um now
the the the
verifier when it picks those tool in our
subspaces um
uh
it has radar correlated
they're correlated and also it has in
mind some hyperplane in in out of decay
now each player should respond with the
unit vector in its subspace okay so
again you have u and v now the real
vectors like we had before
and and they need to fall in subspaces
so so this means right this is a
projection game right because we have
some predicate
uh
right the fact that u is an s or v's and
t right that there is some linear
predicate that we're trying to to
enforce on each vector separately
and what the valid file does is it
checks whether the projection of u and
the projection of v on the hyperplane
are the same okay this is it this is
this is the game
and here is uh what you can do with the
semi-definite uh program
suppose there exists a strategy that er
the verified successful probability one
minus theta which is a very strong
assumption
um
the the thing is that the the an
algorithm can only efficiently guarantee
a square delta
difference l2 difference between the
projections right exactly for the same
reason that that we had before
um
and on conjecture is that this is tight
so if you're trying to do better
no it's going to be empty hard
okay
uh so so so this is our a wishful np
hardness um
and and under this right from this we
can do a reduction
uh to boolean unique games
okay
um okay so
i'm not going to show you the reduction
um
i'm not going to show you the analysis
of the reduction this is just a
a topic for a longer talk and and i
should say that i gave a longer talks
on this work and are available online so
if anyone wants to see the the
description of the reduction and the
analysis
you can do that
but but i do want to highlight this one
big
component the the most difficult um
component in the analysis of the
reduction uh because also because i
think that this is of independent
interest for a bunch of reasons
uh so so here it is
so uh it's a new concentration p1 fold
the low degree part of the real function
okay so here's the theorem fix the
degree right so even the green one is
interesting
but you can fix the green media
take a function a real function here
it's it's defined over the the sphere uh
there is a technical reason why
uh these are easier to work with
um
it doesn't doesn't matter much and in
fact in the in the paper we also we
actually need them over
um over how to decay um
and then yeah right
extends
um the function has bounded to norm okay
now
pick a random hyperplane so this is this
is the hydraulic plane you just pick
this vector that is also known to the
hyperplane
and now you can look at the the function
only restricted to the hyperplane so
this is f restricted to h
um
and right this is a local view
of the function
now for this local view
you can ask what's the what's the low
degree part
of this of this function so this is
what's written uh
in the beginning here
next you can ask about the global view
so so you take the global function f
you look at its low degree part and then
you restrict it
to the hyper plane age
and what this theorem says is that those
two functions are closed
uh in in you know l2 sense right so
think of if if the degree is one maybe
this is a vector
uh the vector of coefficients of the
linear power this is the vector of the
coefficients of the inner part those two
vectors are incredibly um
close
in in euclidean distance
clause up to one over k
there is some dependence on d we think
of d as constant so
we don't care about the dependence on d
and i should say this is tight right
this is the ultimate
theorem to prove in terms of the
deviation if f is a half space indeed
you're going to have a one over k
deviation
let me say that um right you can do sort
of free analysis type technique so if we
are in
over the sphere this is called
gergenpower
analysis
uh
you can write over over um
uh
doesn't space it's called
meat analysis right so the polynomials
you take
for the bases are different but kind of
the the the spirit of the thing is the
same spirit uh so you could do this sort
of fourier type thing to prove some some
um
concentration result but this would give
you a deviation of one over square root
k simply because you'll be analyzing the
the square
of of the distance rather than the
distance
and this is just not good for us this is
completely meaningless when when we talk
about boolean universe exactly because
the whole thing is is whether it's one
minus delta one minus square delta and
you you should think of the delta s as
one over k here
um
so this
right the
kind of standard techniques would have
given you this and and
to get the actual tight result was was
extremely
challenging
and the way we ended up doing that uh
well
for one thing we talked to boss
and he told us about this interesting
technique
used in the past
uh saying in a paper with with uh
with um
where they talked about sampling
function how you have a function it has
some expectation
how does its expectation look on a
hyperlink
right but there is a big difference
between sampling and and
what we need to prove here right between
just maintaining the expectation versus
maintaining the entire the greedy part
um but but the technique is
you use
a shoes
lemma from representation theory
and and what chooselama tells you is
that you can look at the second moment
of this
difference
and and it actually
doesn't depend on the function it only
depends on the spectrum of the function
okay
and
[Music]
so so this says that uh without loss of
generality you can just think of
functions in in two dimensions
um
and and work there
even this problem in two dimensions is
is uh
very challenging
and it it ends up uh being solved with
very careful uh geometric analysis
um
so so this is this is what we what we
did here
um
let me also mention right this is uh
what what in theoretical computer
science we call a low degree testing
theorem right what's a law degree
testing theorem is like you look locally
at the functions the function there
maybe it's close to low degree what can
you say about the function being close
to low degree
globally
right
if you can say that yeah it must be a
close to law degree globally
um
then you get yourself a degree testing
film so so this implies this this
concentration theorem implies a law
degree testing theorem
um
and
right and and this is a completely
different
um technique to prove a lot of degree
testing theorems
um basically by by generalizing in
a highly non-trivial way um
sampling field
in
marital it should be interesting to see
whether
uh generalizing sampling
should be
uh
even more useful for for low degree
testing theorems
anyway so let me end here um
and this is it let me just uh go back
quickly to the main
to the main
picture
this is the main picture
um
right we did this this uh reduction from
the subspaces near intersection problem
to boolean unique games this is a
correct
sound reduction and the hope is that
we'll also get to do this reduction
okay thank you